الاقتصاد سوق الدردشة حار حقًا في
الوقت الحالي وبغض النظر عن
الصناعة ، يواجه الأشخاص مشكلة في
الحفاظ على الأشخاص كيف تتعاملون مع
أن القتال من أجل المواهب شرس ،
ولم أر أبدًا أنه أصعب أو أكثر
تكلفة وحياتي المهنية كلها
الأعمال التجارية للمطعم ، لذا عليك القيام
بعدد من الأشياء التي يجب عليك إنشاء
مكان يؤمن فيه الناس بروح
أن أعضاء الفريق يريدون العمل من أجلها
يجب أن تكون مرتاحًا ، يجب أن تكون
مرنًا ، وعليها القيام بأشياء مثل
الأربعة-  أسبوع العمل اليومي ومن
المهم جدًا بالنسبة لنا أن نكون
شاملين ومتنوعين وهذا ما يجعل الأفضل من
بين أفضل الفرق المقاتلة وفي مكان
يرغب فيه الناس في البقاء لمدة أربعة أيام
في الأسبوع لمدة 40 ساعة في الأسبوع الذي بدأتم به يا رفاق.
كيف تسير الأمور؟ لقد نشأت في
مجال المطاعم منذ أن كان عمري 13 عامًا ، كانت
أيام عمل المطاعم
كما لو كنت تعمل بجد حقًا ،
فأنت لا
تعمل في المنزل أبدًا ستة أيام في الأسبوع و 12 14
ساعة يوميًا و  في الآونة الأخيرة نحن  ابدأ في
تحدي هذه الفكرة ، وفي بعض
أكواخ الساحل الغربي ، بدأنا في اختبار
أسبوع عمل مدته أربعة أيام ، وبالنسبة لعضو الفريق
الذي يعمل في المطاعم
، يعد هذا
تغييرًا جذريًا كبيرًا في نمط حياتهم ، لذلك
نأمل
أن يؤدي هذا الأمر إلى  معدل احتفاظ أفضل
بمرور الوقت ، هذا ما ندرسه ،
وهذا ما نقيسه لمعرفة ما إذا كان هذا ما
يحدث بالفعل ، فأنت تنمو
بسرعة كبيرة في كل من الولايات المتحدة وخارجها.
العثور عليهم من
الخارج ، نريد حقًا تطوير حوالي
نصف قادتنا من الداخل
ونفعل ذلك ، وهناك الكثير من القصص الرائعة
لأشخاص بدأوا في جني تسعة عشرة دولارات 15 دولارًا في
الساعة والآن يقود قادتنا
مناطق هز جاك ولكننا نحب أيضًا  لديك
بعض الأفكار الجديدة التي تعلمها أننا نحب أن
نكون أشخاصًا من مطاعم
التجزئة الأخرى وغيرها من الصناعات التي
يخلق فيها فريق التوازن شيئًا مميزًا حقًا
وهذه هي الطريقة التي نقود بها
شركتنا  مطاعمنا أنا أنظر
إلى المكان الذي تتركز فيه يا رفاق
في هذا البلد ، فأنت
تتعرض فقط لبعض أسواق الأجور المرتفعة جدًا
حيث يوجد حد أدنى للأجور حيث
نحب أن نذهب أو يحصل الناس على الكثير من
المال نحن فيه  في الغالب في نيويورك
والشمال الشرقي اليوم ، كان الكثير من
نمونا في كاليفورنيا وأماكن باهظة الثمن
مثل سياتل بمرور الوقت ،
لقد رفعنا أسعارنا بلطف ولم نرفعها
بقدر ما نستطيع أو ربما
تعرف ما
يجب علينا لكن  نحن متحفظون حقًا
بشأن رغبتنا في التأكد من أن شيك
شاك لا يزال يمثل القيمة الهائلة الجيدة حقًا
للجميع بما في ذلك
الأشخاص الذين يعملون هناك ، انظر إلى ما
نفعله بأيادي كاملة وقلوب كاملة ، إنه
ليس روبوتًا يجعل همبرغر الخاص بك
ضيافته وهذا يتطلب  البشر العظماء
للقيام بذلك
وسنقوم بدفع أجر كبير لهم حتى
نتمكن من المنافسة